going to take some random
words and rap about them yeah i'll give
you like 10 seconds thinking time one
second
you get thinking time also about three
and a half weeks ago at the comedy
seller someone said gabba ghoul
and that is probably going to be
released in about four weeks online so i
can't take the same situation twice but
you now have 10 seconds thinking time to
come up with more
[Music]
people over here what would you like a
rap about
dave chappelle loves transgenders yes
okay
that's the suggestion
dave chappelle loves transgenders not
even transgender people he loves them um
let's come to this
are you pointing at this person yes what
would you like a rap about
riding motorcycles through vietnam my
gosh you look incredibly youthful to
have been there are you
riding motorcycles through vietnam i'm
assuming you mean present-day vietnam
yeah cool cool
no you just reacted as if you'd never
heard of the war you're like no how else
would you take that yeah
yeah through vietnam it's a beautiful
asian country
yeah riding motorcycles through vietnam
i guess that'd be terrible if you i mean
it's sad that like your a country's name
is forever associated with attract it's
awful in it i mean that's how every
other country feels when they hear the
word america as well
okay so dave chappelle loves
transgenders
riding motorcycles for vietnam well yeah
yes my new zealand friend because you
you clearly are a man you clearly are
going to beat the [ __ ] out of me if i
don't take it
ted lasso coaching the all banks okay
i really wish i'd seen the show um
no no i know it's maybe very good it's
got a lot of british comedians in who
are very funny um so there was a hand up
from behind you as well who yeah
jacob what was the final words
okay
it's going to be so niche jacob reese
mogg is he's i do him in the poem he's
like the whitest man in england he is
not my dad thanks for asking he
he's a member of parliament for
northeast somerset he uh he's a real
piece of [ __ ] he's quite right-wing and
old-fashioned he loves like fox hunting
he lounges on the benches in the house
of parliament he's really long and lanky
um but apparently he's a wild man okay
and then people over here and i've just
realized person behind this person with
the antennae have you been able to see
anything for the whole show yeah
i just had like a bullseye over my face
just a target so people over here what
would you like a rap about
oh oh okay
yeah
realizing i'm in the matrix while doing
the wrap and then i guess i didn't come
to the back of the room hey back of the
room what would you like a rap about
well that's good but you're not the back
of the room they're the back of the room
do you have anything better than protein
folding back of the room
the fermi paradox
is that the thing about intelligent life
in the universe
yeah
or wait wait does someone disagree
no that's it is it is it the one is it
the one about like if there was
intelligent life in the universe it like
it can only be us because otherwise it
would have got in touch with us
okay cool i'm just checking
i don't want to be like yeah [ __ ]
spitting about it and you're like mate
you just rapped about a pizzeria what
are you on about
so let's remind you dave chappelle loves
transgenders we have uh jacob reese mogg
is a wild man ted lasso coaching all
blacks riding a motorcycle through
vietnam the fermi paradox may be protein
folding and realism in the matrix this
is too many suggestions
okay right
let's drop that be good sir let's uh rap
about all that [ __ ] for you it's uh it's
gonna be fun yeah
okay
big man nice the third row starting with
you let me coach rugby named ted lasso
ted lasso technically like the rope
maybe as a kiwi your one hope is not
jonah lomu r.i.p he was the biggest guy
that ever played rugby look how excited
he is yeah he really knows they're the
only key we you know is jason momoa but
that's fine paired over he slays this
getting those points jason sedakis used
to be soccer in the uk but down under in
new zealand what would we say like oh
hello mate welcome to the team i sound
slightly australian but give me team
don't worry about that oh there again i
slipped on the floor can you lend me a
pin that's what they all say yeah i
stroll into the lab and i talk about
protein folding i'm looking in there or
all the cells and then a scientist in
the corner she yells like jesus christ
look at what's happening i'm looking at
the tiny little folding while he's
rapping it's coming out no hope you've
got to use a big electron microscope
what does it mean it makes up all the
microbes and the dna atp on those the
mitochondria make me ponder why wait
jesus christ i've got pain behind my
eyes there's a plug at the back of my
head i thought i was alive but i'm
technically dead i'm up here in a bath
it hurts me i say ouchy a movie made by
the wachowskis i'm getting in the bath
looking round quickly there's morpheus
there's trinity they're like neo what is
even happening i'm like i thought i was
a british guy who did the rapping in the
bell house they're like now you wear a
black latex
jacket on the big screen what's next
1999 it was released and since then
while they've had less grief the
wachowskis why i might be friendship why
because they came out as transgender
they yes they did one's called leia and
the other one i'm not sure so i can't
say the name but they made sense eight
for netflix and what else did they do
had such a big hit a man who doesn't go
down well in certain places that's dave
chappelle he's from ohio grew up in nyc
he did an album recently wisely put it
out there people protested they're like
oh dave yes you questioned and suggested
you said women are women and everyone
else but some people are winning and
then on stage with joe rogan recently he
said if you see a trans person give them
coffee say it's from me de chappelle
you've gotta keep up with the news as
well he probably does love them he says
it they're in the special everyone's
tense they'd be testing their metal like
chris can you say this what's the plan
let me talk about this man in vietnam
you'll be going over there it's ever so
vital to have spf on your motorcycle
because you're pale and your hair
slightly red you would burn in vietnam
people have said you'd be there on the
back like single chair thinking about
nam like i was there i was rolling
through saigon riding on my little
kawasaki yamaha that's the right one i
go broom broom stepping there keep in
touch i see a lady and she hops and i
rev that clutch and i'm like yo pretty
do you want to make a reference to your
titties or sucky sucky long time they're
from full metal jacket that's a quote to
a movie so please don't attack it
they'll come back at me and lob through
a lot talk about intelligent life for
paradox of the fermis yeah it feels
really cool i prefer the guy who said
[ __ ] gabba gool but i can't be beat
by rapping about the meat are we
intelligent did people even reach can
they come to us can they see from the
planet if they had a laser would they
understand it could they fly down below
to the fellow come in like the aliens
they're in ufos no cause they don't
exist so we learned these pleas from an
italian man called fermi boom
[Music]
you